you've gotta break out of that pattern
you got a knotless in him and make it
fun and however way you want listen
otherwise you're stuck if you want to
help your mom sometimes the best way to
help your mom is to get out and then
come back and get her out
forget it
so honestly well honestly and I respect
that this is a [ __ ] like this long
you're in a [ __ ] spot right now like
this mall it's some [ __ ] right now it's
when you're 14 it feels like it's your
life forever
you understand surround yourself with as
much positivity to get you through this
I get it but you understand there's no
alternative there's only two choices
here you stay under that roof and eat
[ __ ] for four more years to me more
years two more years or you bounce now
plenty bounce the poor it's not common
in the UK but people do it or you don't
life's about a very simple [ __ ]
option these are doing you know if
you're gonna [ __ ] eat [ __ ] under that
roof you need to put your [ __ ] ear
pods in and listen to positive and 2475
so you understand when your surroundings
are [ __ ] your insides got to be positive
in fact you're even here means you're
[ __ ] halfway home
[Music]
[ __ ] around you have to make it positive
in your head I know it feels like it's
[ __ ] forever and it's too thick
forever when you're 14 or more years
sounds like [ __ ] forever but you have
the choice to either bounce where you
stay and to stay which is more likely
just fine you got to put [ __ ]
positivity in your ears do you
understand I promise you you have no
other alternatives otherwise you just do
well and you go down a spiral that you
don't want to go down you understand